Dresden is famous for its lovely baroque
buildings which draw millions of
visitors each year but during the
Christmas season many come just for the
streets a market it's been a local
tradition for 580 years
I didn't think there would be this much
happening on a weekday lunchtime people
seem to be coming from everywhere but
why what is so fascinating about this
Christmas market one big reason are the
wood carvings handmade here in the
region all around the world these
traditional handicrafts are what people
associate with Christmas and Germany a
large Nutcracker can cost up to 90 euros
so what's the appeal why do people buy
it they're genuine and real I always say
they're made with love these gnomes come
from the forest and they gather up the
pinecones the people who carve these
know that that's what makes them so real
that's the magic of these wooden figures
so it's not kitsch that history and
tradition that's the appeal the streets
and market opens every year within
humanik a service in the Church of the
Holy Cross and that's where I'm meeting
an historian who knows all about it
about two and a half million visitors
come here during the Christmas season
that's five times the population of the
city the historian Goodwin Watson knows
how it all started
let's handle decision in the very
beginning it was a meat market for
violation first after the days of
fasting before Christmas were over the
local Catholics came here to buy their
meat for the holiday of decent macht
that's fly through the fire target
anchor the market remained and
eventually it wasn't just a meat market
anymore
it started offering all sorts of things
the English for course the shop
surrounding the market are also in the
Christmas spirit this bakery sells real
Grayson stone the Christmas cake has
many imitators but only a hundred and
thirty bakeries as certified to sell
Drayson stone good fish stolen has 50%
butter oh and there's flour sugar
raisins and candied lemon peel but no
marzipan the marzipan flavor comes from
the sweet and bitter almonds
according to tradition eating 12 pieces
of stone will bring you luck one piece
for each month of the year yes delicious
and it all smells delicious to the sweet
scent of Christmas is everywhere is that
part of the magic some scientists say it
is there's even some research to prove
it
Tristan's University Hospital has an
institute devoted to taste and smell
Tomas Hummel found out that people can
identify cents like cinnamon and orange
better during the Christmas season and
they find them more appealing in the
winter to the Christmas markets are full
of all sorts of cents so I asked
professor Homer if this is why people
enjoy them so much
this one emits at what could be part of
it christmas is a time of cents cents
evoke memories and emotions too - they
affect us quite deeply and that's one of
the big reasons why people enjoy
Christmas markets as much as they do the
Christmas market casts a spell all its
own but Dresden's market is something
special
why do visitors find it so magical
the Atmos it's the atmosphere the mood
and the people thought every booth is
different and they're all decorated so
nicely a lot of love goes into it this
is something that we cannot find in Asia
this historic district is beautiful it's
really really great punch I love all the
little handicrafts vehicle yeah
handicrafts Christmas cake a wonderful
atmosphere and more
it's no wonder Dresden streets the
market is so popular the brightly lit
carousel is also part of the tradition
even adults love it
the best thing about this market is that
I've met so many people will really
share the Christmas spirit
and in the end perhaps this is what
really draws the crowd